anyone it's my bottles and welcome to
the order flows market analysis for
Friday September 15 2017 big update was
a big update we ended up the week ended
up the day on new highs dial hit a
record of 22 to 68 it was up about to
point to just over 2% for the week
SPS hit that magical 2500 level and on
the way up with some very very strong
trade going on up there at those high
levels from 90 95 all the way up to
double oh excuse me next week we got the
FOMC meeting signs are pointing towards
rising expectations for possibly the
beginning of the balance sheet unwinding
so we'll see what's going to happen next
week before we get started brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision Futures Trading
contains a stretch or a risk and it's
not for every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading in only those with sufficient
risk a people should consider trading
past performance it's not necessarily
indicative of future results tools were
using this presentation are the order
flows trader which is the volume
footprint chart the Delta scalper and
the price rejector okay so let's take us
take a look at the SPS since we had a
record close today let me get the chart
here okay so you know earlier this
morning it kind of a quiet early morning
going into the cash session we just
before the cash session you had the
Delta scalper giving you a buy here then
right before the cash session you start
seeing some decent very strong volume
coming in you know buying imbalances
three thousand two and a half thousand
you know right after right after you got
the Delta scalper signaling that you
know potentially you got very aggressive
buyers coming in and you could start
seeing a demand driven market like I
said you know we had that Korean missile
launch early and let's say early in the
morning but it was it was Thursday night
after the after the the normal session
closed SMP as we sold off but you know
we
started recovering pretty quickly and
you know to me that was a sign that we
could possibly get a rally during the
day session why because you know the
market is shrugging off what's happening
in Korea so coming into the day session
coming into the cash open we're seeing
some signs of life
you know signs that hey you know what
this market may rally up take out the
highs and keep going higher so what I
really want to look for is are there any
signs coming in this is a good sign here
you know you see just headed the cash
opening very aggressive buying coming in
you got Delta scalper you got these nice
chunky and balances with 1120 400 3,000
normally don't get numbers like that
just ahead of pre cash actually during
normally during right ahead of cash
session sometimes you get a more of a
thinning out of volume we're sort of
quiets down and then the algo start
kicking in but it really looks to me
like people are getting started a little
bit early in anticipation of the
smartcut rallying now look what's
happening here at cash opens 8:30
look at these volumes going through on
this is a four range chart you're seeing
some very strong volumes eight thousand
six thousand six thousand seven thousand
that's that strong numbers you know you
got to know the volumes that your
markets trade you know people that don't
look at volume are really leaving a lot
of information on the table but we're
not going anywhere
we're just trading sideways what does
that mean you know it's you know people
are happy to trade at these levels I'll
grant it it's right up off our highs you
know our lifetime highs are up here so
you know people are happy to transfer
the risk and you know maybe for some
people taking risk off the table now
this bar here I found very very
interesting it's enough candle but it's
got a very strong negative Delta and but
look at this volume down here 6,000
7,000 and what's it coming at look at
this this area here just sort of draw
this line and get the crosshairs and of
course you're not working but there we
go anyway it's things NinjaTrader
sometimes pisses me off but 2491
you have to sort of scroll back where is
it it's coming in right around that area
right above the area where you just had
the aggressive buying pre cash
so you know that earlier just sort of
precache you had some very aggressive
buying which is you know again you know
for a precast session these are very big
numbers you don't normally get vine and
bounces like this or even volume like
this right ahead of the cash so that's
already tipping me off to something
again you know that's that's something
that everybody's gonna be able to pick
up on but over here you're seeing some
very strong support of vine you got a
very strong negative delta 6400 if
you're seeing negative Delta like that
you should be looking at this market you
know selling off going down to 88 it's
not they're they're strong buyers here
and it just happens to coincide with the
strong buying aggressive mind that was
here earlier so you know these the
strong buyer or buyers here are happy to
support this market and what happens as
you start creeping up creeping up you're
going up here you get into these highs
you got some imbalances right ahead of
the highs let me take out the highs you
know you're not seeing the big volumes
coming in just yet though we come up
here we shoot up to 96 and 3/4 start
coming off you're now you're seeing
selling imbalances 1 2 3 4 you do have a
buying imbalance in here ok then you
just start going sideways in here up
here you do have a divergence point of
control up near the high I'd I prefer or
a show somewhere up in here this bar
this party gated here it's a little too
far out and then you just sort of go
sideways and you just in in this area
look at this volume you're trading very
strong volume well at the time at the
time this was really sticking out you
didn't have the volume a period but this
was really gigantic you're looking on a
on a four range chart excuse me and
you're seeing look at these volumes here
I get this out of the way thirteen
thousand ten thousand you know even here
nine thousand eight thousand these are
very strong volumes
now again you know what's this market
telling you you up here near your high
you got negative Delta negative Delta
negative Delta positive small positive
strong negative strong positive super
strong negative super strong negative
and what's the market doing is the
market selling off yet or not
again you know let's you know try and
use your brain you know I hate they say
that I hate that phrase cuz I had a boss
that would when someone would do
something stupid he would say use your
brain and you know sometimes people just
can't help but doing stupid stuff but
you know I just did it I don't know that
that phrase just rubs me the wrong way
but anyway we strung Delta four thousand
twenty four hundred but look this bar is
green it's up right so buying came back
in so even though you had a strong
selling right if you're looking at you
know delta of four thousand on a for
range chart again you know they're
strong selling but why isn't the market
selling off you know that's what you got
to be asking you know sometimes the most
the best trade is the trade that sort of
runs contrary to you know what you're
expecting you're expecting the market to
start selling off your up here near the
high you got strong negative delta yet
the market is holding why why do you
have the negative delta then because you
have very strong support of mine just
because you have strong negative delta
you know that's one thing but then you
got to take it to the next step well why
isn't the market selling off with a
strong negative delta well it's because
you got strong buyers up here you got
strong appeal people bidding this market
supporting this market and you can see
it with these bars creeping back up
creeping back up creaking creeping back
up so even though you got the negative
delta but if you have negative delta
with you know a bar that's turning
higher that's the sign of support of
buying and what happens you're just
spinning your wheels in here you're
trading a huge amounts of volume forty
nine thousand sixty one thousand ice a
huge amount some time about huge amounts
for a forming chart you know for a ten
range chart this would be you know just
your average volume but on a four range
chart you know these are very strong
volume numbers and the markets not
budging
well we're up here near our lifetime
highs so you know people like that are
transferring risk covering positions
right now you're not necessarily seeing
people coming in and you know putting on
new positions what would we assign a new
sign would be you know some nice
aggressive mind you're just not really
seeing that again you know you're coming
into Friday here at lifetime highs who
knows what's going to happen over the
weekend with Korea you just had a terror
attack in London
you know the world what's going on you
know nowadays you got all this stuff
happening and the markets rally instead
of selling off but again you know these
this is sign of supportive buying in
here right in here over these four or
five bars in here supportive buy and you
got the strong negative Delta's in the
markets not selling off so what that
means is you got my incoming in
supportive buying here pointing control
right at the bottom look at this volume
4600 even here 6000 so even though these
markets are you know the bars are sort
of dipping down dipping down you're met
with strong buying then you get up here
you know you got the divergence that
failed yet excuse me divergence
divergence divergence divergence at a
ratio Delta scalper you're taking hey
it's cash closed it's Friday maybe we're
gonna start selling off do you know you
don't even though you got negative Delta
all hanging around up here
you know BP be wary be wary if if the
markets not selling off you know over
here it's ready you know 3:30 markets
closing in 30 minutes you get that last
push up you know for people to print
2500 so there really was no strong sell
signs you know you mean I can make the
argument that here late in the day there
was but again you know at 3 o'clock on
Friday afternoon cash just closed he
really will be messing around taking a
short you know why I mean there's no
reason to I mean you can you make you
make that argument yeah the ratio the
divergence Delta scalper you got some
Cylon imbalances in there but again here
you've been fighting all day long with
very supportive buying you know what's
your capacity for a trade is it gonna
sell off three or four handles no it's
not most likely but in the end just sort
of pops up another two handles to hit a
new contract high so that was
interesting you know I said it's
supportive buying you know is this
something that people don't really talk
about very much but you know it's in the
markets and you could see it in the
order flowed you just gotta take your
order flow analysis another step further
than just rather reading the Delta you
gotta read the Delta and think about it
y-you know again you got the strong
negative Delta which would normally
indicate the market selling off but if
it's not
and off investigate and take it a step
further right it's not like you know the
you know those murder mystery shows you
know someone gets shot and then a kid
picks up a gun in the street
oh you're guilty no okay why is the gun
in the street you know then you go oh
you work backwards from there it's not
just like the last person that touched
the gun is guilty and it's just like
that you know you just don't stop at
reading the Delta now you read the Delta
in context of what's happening in the
market okay the other market I'll talk
about really quick here is the soybeans
soybeans you know soybeans are a great
market they don't get the credit they
deserve but they're a terrific contract
for trading
so 8:30 a.m. is is the reopen after you
know there's a there's a period where
it's closed for like an hour from the
evening session to the normal cash hour
I say cash hours but the normal the
normal day session so you know when we
open up 8:30 we start rallying up here
we get up to this high you got a
divergence that fails I said you had a
divergence with no ratio you got 35 lots
and then a few minutes later you come
back up you test that high again what do
you got you got your divergence your
ratio your price rejecter you've got a
single print of one first time you hit
it you got 35 so what's that telling you
I love every time you hit a high you
test a high or a low and you get less
volume it's telling me you're getting
signs of price rejection and you just
could see it also in the order flow with
the bearish ratio it's a racial balance
high indicating price rejection you got
the price rejecter giving you a sell
signal
you've got the single print again which
also indicates price rejection it's nice
to get the the divergence as well and
what happens over you know the next
bunch of bars you know you start trading
lower from nine seventy six and a half
and you get all the way down to you know
973 972 and a half eventually you get
down here to the 972 area you know but
you know realistically you should be
looking at covering it somewhere around
in here so you know that's a three cent
move three cents in the soybeans is like
three points in the sps it's twelve and
a half cents a tick and trades in
pennies so there's there's four ticks to
a penny a penny is 50 bucks that's a
three cent move right there you know
eventually
you you know you just go sideways and
then sell off some more but again you
know one could have got a quick three
cents now again something kind of
similar here you hit this low nine sixty
seven and a quarter you trade five Lots
first time second time three Lots so
you're seeing you know less volume you
know there's not much difference between
five and three I'll be honest with you
but again optically that's what you're
looking for
price rejecter price rejecter so you
already know here on the first bar that
there's some signs of price rejection
with the price rejecter coming in second
bar again you got a price rejecter now
you got the divergence you don't have
the divergence the first time and now
you got the bullish ratio thirty one and
you know a single print as well and what
happens is this market starts creeping
back up so you know again you know if
you're buying it here in the next bar
nine sixty eight and a half what happens
it starts rallying nine sixty eight and
a half boom boom boom this is the Delta
surge right here you could see the Delta
sixteen 139 four fifty three so you're
getting some very strong buy-in coming
in here but again you know the sign was
here right off this low just as the sign
earlier was right up there at the high
that this mark is gonna start rallying
in this case you know before at the high
it was talking about selling off now you
come up here so nine sixty eight and a
half boom you trade all the way up here
you get a stack sound imbalances that
isn't you know that's a sign that maybe
you should think about taking it off so
sixty eight and a half up to seventy
three and a half this area up in here
that's that's a sick sent move so three
cents earlier six cents here you know
six cents on one contract is is three
hundred bucks
right six times fifty bucks and okay so
you lighten it up now you got again you
know let's just talk about what's
happening right in here so you got the
bearish sign in here with the stacks on
it balance the whole bar almost is all
song imbalances you don't have it on the
very top level you got the price
rejecter also giving you a sign that you
know this market is rejecting prices up
here well what happens in the next bar
very fast it comes right back you got a
bullish ratio so you got a stacks on
imbalance and it comes back with almost
a stack behind imbalance if I had this
set at a lower number I have a set at
fifty as my minimum volume threshold
zero against 39 if I had this said I'd
say you know 25 or you know I set the
set at 38 you know I don't have a stack
by an imbalance here which is something
you know that would be bullish actually
but you know I have it set at 5050 is is
by default level I use smaller numbers
and things like Nasdaq and some of the
currencies but so you had your stack
selling a balance but then you come
right back with a bullish ratio which is
not good a bunch of imbalances so again
you know if you are long from earlier
down off that low coming up into this
area you know you're getting some
conflicting signals right here I mean
honestly what this stacks on a balance
you should be looking at you have cut
the position anyway you know whether
she'd be getting along not really not
yet again you got this very bullish
bearish bar followed by a bullish bar
okay what to do while you wait for the
next bar you don't know what's putting a
gun to your head say no you got to trade
this bar know wait for the next bar to
come in and see if anything's clearer
you know is this market gonna go up or
go down what do you got here you got a
point of control right at the high you
got a bearish ratio you got this
imbalance up here and then the market
sold off again it sold off right into
this area this is actually a very
bearish bar again when every time you
get these pointy controls on the extreme
is very bearish if it's a red bar if it
was a green bar would be on the bottom
and that would be bullish so this bar by
itself is bearish no you know you knew
earlier you had some aggressive selling
you had some you had the price rejecter
so you know you had some signs of you
know price rejection up here now you're
getting price I don't want say support
it's it's resistance you know but you're
getting you know price defense up here I
don't like to use the term support the
proper word for it would be defense so
people are defending these prices up
here now you know before you're coding
you know buyers were rejecting the
prices up here whereas now you got
sellers defending this price up here so
you got an area where you know buyers
were a bit hesitant to tread early and
then the selling came in and then he
came back up here buyers started getting
aggressive you come back up here and you
know there's strong sellers up here you
could see it in the volume to 39 100 you
got the bearish ratio that's a sign that
this market
could possibly sell off again you know I
like this type of bar you know with the
imbalance on the high the Pony control
at the top the bearish ratio and what
happens is this market sells off again
from 973 all the way back down a 979 71
where you get the knot the scalper
kicking in it just sort of goes sideways
on you but again you know from 973 down
to even nine even then here at nineteen
seventy one that's another two cents
you had six cents two cents five cents
that's ready eleven cents yeah maybe
this one you take this trade it fails on
you you know you'll lose you know penny
or two but you still end up with it with
a nice day again that's soybeans right
again you know everyone is focused on
things like crude oil emini snps euro
currency and sometimes you know they
lose sight of a lot of the other good
contracts that are available for trading
and soybean is a good contract you know
for trade listen it doesn't necessarily
get the respect it it deserves but again
it's something that follows order flow
quite nicely so let's just take a look
at I don't know one other quick chart
what is this
so the Nasdaq I did some Nasdaq trading
earlier but anyway um as precache but
let's take a look here what's what it
looks like here from the cash open so
you gotta sell here ten work out think I
nice buy you know fifty nine sixty five
all the way up here to seventy-five you
know the stuff you out stop do out stop
you ought to stop you out again this is
a Union wrinkle chart they got a nice
buy here so yeah you had some nice
bodies even though you had some cells
that failed again you lost your trending
market you can get these trades that
fail on a trending market it sort of
sucks but you know there was plenty of
plenty of trades that were profitable in
the S and in the successful is the term
you're supposed to use nowadays can't
use the word profitable if these were
successful in the Nasdaq
Dax Dax the Union Renko chart there's a
delta scalper again you had crushed it
if you're trading decks with the Delta
scalper today this right off the high of
the day twelve five thirty five all the
way down to you know five hundred and
you know not the strongest move you know
it's not a hundred euro 100 ticket move
but you know hey anytime you can get a
sell signal light off the high down
towards you know your lows of the day
somewhere in here you know say you're
covered in here you know that's one more
can you ask for you know people want the
sell signal up here and the buy signal
down here unfortunately doesn't always
come down here you know you can only do
what the market lets you do okay let's
see what else really quick okay so go
back to equities here this is the no I
am the mini dial this morning and you
know they kept talking about
above-average volume you know it's hard
if you're just trading a normal bar
chart to really understand the volumes
that's going through here so you know
rallying here this morning is just you
know take it from the cash open here at
8:30 you have a divergence here right on
8:30 here you got the imbalance right on
the high but I know this markets you
know going through the cash opening so
I'm not really too concerned
8:31 you got another divergence you got
a bearish ratio you got a single print
Delta scalper okay the market doesn't
come off yet this is 831 so cash just
open now you're starting to put in some
very strong volume for the mini down at
a range chart you know 400 400 400 400
you got a divergence and a ratio again
you know you had one here earlier the
market isn't sell-off you hit this high
again you come back up within two ticks
of that you got another single print but
again you'll say you're taking this shot
and you know at this point you don't
know yet if the markets gonna go higher
or lower you know what you're looking at
a bunch of bearish signs up here so
maybe you get short does it sell off not
really come starts coming down to this
opening price here you know again this
is you know over the next 20 minutes
you're sort of hanging around here you
do poke lower down into the you know the
170s
so from you know the 185 you know
90 area down into the 170 175 area so
not a big move by any stretch of the
imagination then you start working your
way back up methodically mm-hmm get back
up here so again you just had one two
three divergences watch if it's gonna
fail or not okay watch if we're gonna
take out the high and boom you take out
that high honestly what I'm looking at
three failed divergences right there and
I see we're just hanging around there hi
I'm looking for this high to keep coming
back being tested and you know to me I'd
buy it if it hit that high no it could
hit the high and make a new high by one
or two ticks or then sell off okay
that's the chance he got to take right
or you can hit the high and rally and
other 20 points so what do we do we hit
that high and we take it out we take it
out quite nicely we go up from 195 all
the way up to 214 you got another
divergence no ratio you got a divergence
the next bar you got the ratio you got
the Delta scalper you got the Balto's
transition coming in and again you know
if you're looking at short it would be
somewhere around here 200 area 20 to 200
198 and unfortunately just goes sideways
on you it just goes nowhere
initially it sells off over the next
over this bar and the next bar it gets
down to 190 and then it just literally
hangs around that area over the next one
two three four bars you know honestly in
here you'd be looking to cover it there
if you could get out of this with a
scratch that would be a terrific trade
but again if it's it's giving you the
sell signal right here at 10 o'clock
right 10:25 it's still just hanging
around that area 1037 1049 you know it's
already almost an hour since you're
entering that position and it's going
nowhere again that's another sign that
you should be getting out and you're
putting in some decent volumes in here
you know in a bar 2900 1700 you know
don't expect this market to go sideways
on you for an hour or two or then make
the move you know know if you're getting
the signals look for the move to happen
right it's not gotas you know oh there's
a signal okay I'll take the trade go to
sleep and wake up
oh the move should happen right if
you're seeing a transition a change from
supply to demand or demand in this case
from demand to supply because he just
rallied up and you're seeing supply
coming in and well that supply that's
coming in it should overwhelm the buyers
and the market should sell-off it
shouldn't just hang around the you know
around that price where you're getting
the sign that it's it's setting up for a
potential sell-off and instead what does
it do it just sort of hangs around that
area that's not a good sign
so again you know if you get out of this
trade at a break even or even a small
couple tick loss and okay but you know
you had a decent trade here on this move
up you know hopefully could have got
something out of there I mean there
wasn't that great a movie was about 20
ticks but still I'm not saying that you
were sold right up there on the high you
know maybe you would have caught
something quick 10 ticks er anyway would
rally back up excuse me get something to
drink
we rarely back up and new high another
divergence that fails get a new high
ratio and divergence up here again you
know can you sell it yeah of course you
can it's right ahead of the cash close
though again it's Friday afternoon
you're right at your contract highs cash
close yeah honestly I I wouldn't be a
seller I mean though the market did sell
off a little bit you know I'm not gonna
say yeah this was a great trading to
take you know again I I know it's gonna
be a lot of while I'm going through on
the cash close we're rallying we're up
at our contract highs I don't know what
the flow is gonna look like in which
direction you know if it's going to be
buying or selling but again you know
Friday afternoon cash closed on lifetime
highs do you want to be a seller high I
don't like that honestly I wouldn't do
anything you know I'm not gonna say yeah
it did sell off here because you would
have sold it at 20 to 22 and we
uncovered it down here no you wouldn't
have most likely would have sold it here
and then it's just going sideways for 30
minutes and you just you know scratch
scratch the trade hopefully or you know
maybe got one or two ticks out of it
covered your commish and that's about it
honestly you're not I'm not gonna say
yeah you would have done that and
covered it down here no that would be
that'd be being outright
falsehood okay so thanks for watching
this video to learn more about the
trading software or floats go to or
Flo's calm and to learn more about the
delta scalper go to delta scalper calm
and have a great weekend everyone and
stay safe bye bye